hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on monster underworld again
and today we're gonna be continuing our
series where we do an in-depth guide on
every monster in Monster Hunter world by
showing off that specific monsters
movesets weaknesses while also giving
you tips about the recommended loadout
to bring for the fight and what's used
in the environment so as always like
divet ii if you do enjoy subscribe if we
knew I covered the in-depth guides of
every monster and Monster Hunter world I
also cover the news and future updates
of Monster Hunter world such as future
content new monsters all that good stuff
and cover the weekly event quests and
let you know which ones to do and what
the rewards are so today's monster we're
gonna be looking at is Oregon or Rollie
pollie either one works hopefully at in
butcher the name or this is gonna be a
really painful video and to start off
according to the report his head and
underbelly are his only two weak points
with this tail head and back being
breakable or severable and for max
damage output always go for the face
moving on it says that he is weakest to
water for the elements and for ailments
it's poison and stun really recommended
loadout I recommend using the essentials
like mega and max potions as well as
anything like a vitality mentor or
possibly a Rocksteady mantle if you have
it he does also do flame damage so you
can use the fireproof mental as well as
well as other things like demon drugs
hardshell powders anything like that you
could obviously bring into the fight if
you want it but now that this quick
introductions over let's get into his
moveset first move is his tail swipe
where he flings his tail at you while
also doing damage to you he can release
these balls of fire that basically stay
implanted on the ground they're kind of
like mines if he rolls on top of these
balls they will explode and if he
doesn't they will actually end up
exporting after certain amount of time
has gone past staying away from his
backside or dodge rolling away should
avoid all damage for this next up he has
a move called the roly-poly move I like
to call it where he starts to do this
little dance jiggle where he releases
more fireballs and then starts rolling
around the map trying to run you over if
you dodge with a lot of this you just
need to keep a close eye on him just the
case he sneaks around behind you and
watch out for the balls around you just
in case you get hit or you're gonna take
some flame damage as always if you do
happen to take flame damage just roll
three times and the flames should go
away just almost instantly next up he
has his push attack where he pushes you
to do some minor damage to start the
attack he opens his mouth and then
angles his body away from you and then
pushes towards you as shown in the clip
he also has a sleep move where he
generates sleep toxin from his
belly and releases it around him if
caught you'll be put in sleep and then
you actually be hit by the next move he
does since sleep takes a while to get
out of so run away as fast as possible
during this park fergan also has a chin
slam where he slams his chin on the
ground new some intense damage so
definitely try to stay away from his
face only because the top of his head is
the most weakest which you can usually
get there doing a sliding attack or if
you want to mount him so as I said
definitely stay away from his face so
try to focus more on the underbelly
during the fight now the moves are over
with let's move into some area info so
there really isn't much info on the area
since there really isn't much it's a
very wide and open area so you don't
really need to be worrying about his
roly-poly moves just like I said just
keep a quick eye on him and you'll be
fine because the areas that you fight
him in are very large and open and then
on top of that the first area usually
fight him and has Neera toads and para
toads to either inflict blast or
paralysis damage on to Oregon so
definitely use that while you have the
chance to get some free hits as always
if there's anything I missed leave it in
the comments below for your fellow
hunters to understand so everybody could
be caught up on how to defeat Eragon as
quick as possible this would be the end
of the video today guys selectively if
you did enjoy subscribe if you like I
said I cover the in-depth guides for
every monster a monster hunter world I
also covered the news and future updates
of monster world like a new monsters or
anything balance changes or stuff like
that and I cover the weekly event quest
and let you know which ones to do and
what the rewards are my two most recent
videos are gonna be on screen if you
guys are gonna check that out went that
guy's so brave a great yesterday thank
you for watching the video
and peace out